resolvamos un ejercicio un poquito más
complicado que el que vimos en el vídeo
pasado tenemos aquí x menos 3 / x + 4
mayor o igual que 2 y este es un
ejercicio un poquito más complicado
porque aquí tenemos mayor o igual y
además aquí no tenemos un simple pero
tenemos un 2 que es mayor que 0 entonces
no es el mismo ejercicio pero lo vamos a
resolver casi casi que de la misma forma
también lo vamos a resolver de dos
formas distintas pero en este ejercicio
voy a cambiar el orden entonces pues
empecemos aquí una opción muy tentadora
es tomar x + 4 y multiplicarlo de los
dos lados de la desigualdad pero como
vimos en el vídeo pasado tenemos que
tener mucho cuidado con esto porque si
tenemos una desigualdad y la
multiplicamos por alguna cosa si esa
cosa que en este caso queremos que sea x
+ 4
y x4 es mayor que 0 entonces multiplicar
de los dos lados de la desigualdad no va
a afectar la desigualdad en cambio si x
+ 4 es menor que cero y multiplicamos de
los dos lados por x más 4 entonces
tenemos que voltear esta desigualdad
aunque entonces vamos a ver esos dos
casos entonces en un caso lo que tenemos
es que x + 4 es mayor que 0
gei mayor estricto que 0 x más 4 no
puede ser igual a 0 porque si fuera
igual a cero esta expresión racional no
estaría bien definida aunque entonces
uno de los casos es cuando x + 4 es
mayor que 0 y esto es exactamente
equivalente a decir que x es mayor que
menos 4 ok para pasar de aquí a acá solo
restamos 4 de los dos lados del mayor
que y estas dos desigualdades son
exactamente equivalentes
entonces por el momento vamos a suponer
que x es mayor que menos cuatro aunque x
mayor que menos cuatro y entonces x más
cuatro es mayor que cero así es que si
multiplicamos x más cuatro de los dos
lados de esta desigualdad la desigualdad
se queda tal cual como está y tenemos x
menos 3 / x + 4 tenemos por aquí un 2
y vamos a multiplicar por x + 4 de los
dos lados y como x 4 es mayor que cero
porque x es mayor que menos 4 y aquí
teníamos mayor o igual que entonces esto
se queda tal cual como está y la razón
por la que hicimos esto es para que este
se cancele con este y entonces nos queda
que x menos 3 es mayor o igual que 2 por
x 2 x + 2 por 4 que es 8 y ahora que
podemos hacer
bueno pues podemos restar x de los dos
lados de esta desigualdad y entonces nos
queda que menos 3 que es mayor o igual
que 2 x menos x una x más 8 y ahora lo
que podemos hacer es deshacernos de este
más 8 restando 8 de los dos lados de la
desigualdad y entonces nos queda que x
es menor o igual que menos 3 menos 8 que
es menos 11
entonces si x es mayor que menos 4 para
que se satisfaga esta desigualdad x
tiene que ser menor o igual que menos
oms que x menor o igual que menos 11
ahora ya vieron muy bien lo que está
pasando aquí estas dos cosas no pueden
pasar al mismo tiempo ok
x no puede ser mayor que menos 4 y menor
o igual que menos 11 al mismo tiempo y
bueno creo que tal vez y dibujamos una
recta numérica esto va a ser más claro
tenemos aquí nuestra recta numérica
tenemos por aquí el 0 tenemos por aquí
el menos 4 y tenemos por aquí el menos
11 bueno de hecho déjame extiendo un
poco más la recta numérica pero el
chiste es que x mayor que menos 4
significa que la x no toca al 4 pero que
la x
cualquier número que se encuentre de
este lado de la recta numérica y x menor
o igual que menos 11 significa que xy
puede tomar el valor de 11 y puede tomar
cualquier valor que esté a la izquierda
de menos 11 y entonces si buscamos que x
sea mayor que menos 4 y menor o igual
que menos 11 estamos buscando alguna x
que se encuentre dentro de los dos
conjuntos al mismo tiempo pero no puede
haber ni una sola equis que haga eso
entonces si suponemos que x es mayor que
menos 4 no tenemos ninguna solución a
esta desigualdad ok entonces podemos
ignorar este caso este caso nos sirve y
ahora lo que nos toca es analizar el
resto de los casos posibles ok entonces
ya vimos que ninguna de las x es que son
mayores que menos 4 puede ser solución
de esta desigualdad así es que ahora
tenemos que ver si alguna de las x es
que son menores o iguales que menos 4
puede ser una solución a ésta
igualdad ahora algo muy importante que
ya habíamos visto antes es que x no
puede ser igual a menos 4 porque si x es
igual a menos 4 entonces aquí estamos
dividiendo entre 0 y entonces esta
fracción está indeterminada
así es que aquí tenemos que borrar este
menos y vamos a analizar el caso en que
x es menor que menos 4
x
menor que menos 4 ahora x es menor que
menos 4 si y sólo si x + 4 es menor que
cero
estas dos desigualdades son equivalentes
pero esta desigualdad no sirve mucho
porque podemos tomar esta desigualdad
que nos dice que x menos 3 /
4 es mayor o igual que 2
y podemos multiplicar de los dos lados
por x + 4 x + 4 pero como x + 4 es menor
que cero entonces en lugar de tener un
mayor o igual como teníamos por acá
la desigualdad se voltea y entonces
tenemos que este es menor o igual que
este otro aquí ya partir de aquí vamos a
hacer prácticamente lo mismo que aquí
nada más que con la desigualdad volteada
de x + 4 se cancela con x + 4 y nos
queda que x menos 3 es menor o igual que
2 por x 2 x + 2 por 48 entonces restamos
una x de los dos lados de la desigualdad
y nos queda que menos 3 es menor o igual
que 2 x menos x es una x
8 y ahora queremos dejar a la equis
solita entonces restamos 8 de los dos
lados y nos queda menos 3 menos 8 eso es
menos 11 menor o igual que equis y listo
tenemos que x
tiene que ser mayor o igual que menos 11
en el caso en el que x es menor que
menos 4 se satisface esta desigualdad
cuando x es mayor o igual que menos 11
aunque entonces podemos poner aquí
nuestra recta numérica
0 - 4 - 11 entonces que nos dice esta
desigualdad nos dice que x tiene que ser
menor estricto que menos 4 aunque
entonces x no puede ser igual a menos 4
así es que lo ponemos aquí una bolita
vacía y esta desigualdad nos dice que x
puede estar en cualquier lugar de estos
aunque vive aquí hasta el infinito pero
para este lado eso es lo que nos dice
esta desigualdad
esta desigualdad lo que nos dice es que
x tiene que ser mayor o igual que menos
11 aunque como es un mayor o igual
entonces x xi puede tomar el valor de
menos son centros le ponemos un puntito
cerrado por aquí x tiene que estar por
aquí
y puede tomar cualquier valor por acá
hasta el infinito ahora lo que nosotros
necesitamos es una equis que cumpla
estas dos desigualdades así es que x
definitivamente tiene que estar dentro
de este intervalo y entonces tiene que
estar en este intervalo tiene que estar
en la intersección de estas dos cosas o
sea tiene que estar en cualquier punto
por acá que no incluye al menos cuatro
pero si incluye al menos 11
todas estas x satisfacen esta
desigualdad entonces pues necesito más
espacio porque ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es resolver esta desigualdad pero
de la otra forma
ok entonces vamos a volver a escribir el
problema pero ahora en otro color
tenemos que x menos 3 / x + 4 es mayor o
igual que 2 aunque hay queremos
encontrar todas las x que hacen que se
satisfaga esta ecuación y espero que te
acuerdes de un problema que hicimos por
ahí donde teníamos a / t mayor que 0 y
lo que dijimos es que a / b es mayor que
0 si sólo si hay b tienen el mismo signo
o sea si es mayor que 0 y b es mayor que
0 o si a es menor que 0 y b es menor que
cero que entonces vamos a hacer lo mismo
con esta ecuación pero aquí tenemos el
asunto de que de este lado de la
desigualdad tenemos 12 en lugar de un 0
y si en serio necesitamos que haya un 0
por acá entonces la solución es restar
menos dos de los dos lados de la
desigualdad así es que tenemos que
3 / x + 4 menos dos es mayor o igual que
0 y aquí no tenemos ningún problema a la
hora de restar el 2 no se modifica esta
desigualdad recuerda que a la hora de
sumar o restar las desigualdades se
quedan tal cual como están el único
problema el único momento en el que
tenemos que poner mucha atención es
cuando estamos multiplicando aquí pero
aquí nada más restamos así es que todo
está muy bien el único asunto es que
esto no está en una forma de una
fracción pero eso se arregla muy
fácilmente
ok porque este menos 2 lo podemos ver
como una fracción de menos 2 es
exactamente igual a menos 2 por 1
cierto bueno pero este uno puede tomar
muchísimas formas por ejemplo puede
tomar la forma de x + 4 entre x + 4
así es que esto es igual a menos 2
por x + 4 / x 4 porque además estamos
suponiendo que la x es distinta de menos
4 para que esta fracción esté bien
determinada entonces esto está muy bien
y esto es exactamente igual a menos 2
por x más 4 - 2 por x es menos 2x y
luego menos 2 x más 4 eso es menos 8 / x
esto de aquí es igual a menos 2 gay es
exactamente igual a esto de aquí
así es que podemos simplemente
sustituirlo x menos 3 / x + 4 y
sustituimos nuestro menos 2 - 2 y
entonces tenemos aquí más
- 2 x menos 8 / x + 4 y convenientemente
de hecho ese es el truco principal estos
dos tienen el mismo denominador ok pero
bueno esto es igual a esto que es mayor
o igual que 0 entonces como tiene el
mismo denominador podemos sumarlo y lo
que nos queda es tenemos aquí x más 4 x
menos 2x eso es simplemente un menos
equis y luego menos tres menos ocho eso
es un -11 y queremos que esto sea mayor
o igual que cero ok entonces acabamos de
llevar esta desigualdad a esta forma
esta forma de aquí estas dos
desigualdades son exactamente
equivalentes aquí está todo el proceso y
esta desigualdad ya tiene la forma que
estábamos buscando que es esta forma
entonces ya podemos aplicar lo que vimos
en este vídeo para desigualdades de esta
forma aunque entonces lo que vimos en
este vídeo es que el numerador y el
denominador tienen que ambos ser mayores
que 0 osea necesitamos que menos x menos
11 sea mayor o igual que 0 y que x más 4
sea mayor estricto que 0 tiene que ser
distinto de 0 porque si no esta fracción
está indeterminada y este es uno de esos
dos casos en los que esta fracción es
mayor o igual que 0 este es un caso
entonces puede pasar esto o puede pasar
que el numerador y el denominador sean
menores que 0
así es que menos x menos 11 es menor o
igual que 0 y el denominador es menor
que 0
y x4 es menor que 0 x + 4 es menor que
cero
si esto pasa es porque pasan alguno de
estos dos casos y si pasa alguno de
estos dos casos entonces sucede esta
desigualdad
así es que pues vamos a analizar estos
casos si menos x menos 11 es mayor o
igual que 0 menos 11 tiene que ser mayor
o igual que x y xi x + 4 es mayor que 0
x tiene que ser mayor que menos 4 así es
que en este caso x tiene que ser menor o
igual que menos 11 y también tiene que
ser mayor que menos 4 así es que las dos
cosas tienen que pasar pero en este
momento nos damos cuenta que hay cierto
problema con este caso y es el hecho de
que menos 4 es mayor que menos 11
entonces no existe ni un solo número que
sea mayor que menos 4 y menor que menos
11 aunque no hay ni un solo número que
cumpla con estas dos desigualdades
así es que este caso no nos aporta
ninguna solución a la desigualdad y
entonces nos vamos con el siguiente caso
que íbamos a buscar x que cumplen estas
dos desigualdades y si x satisface esta
desigualdad menos 11 es menor o igual
que x aunque hay nada máximo no la x de
los dos lados y por aquí vamos a sumarle
menos cuatro de los dos lados nos queda
la desigualdad x menor que menos 4
entonces estamos buscando x que cumplan
con estas dos desigualdades y como menos
4 si es mayor que menos 11 entonces sí
puede haber x que cumplan con ambas
desigualdades que tenemos aquí nuestra
recta numérica
al menos cuatro el menos once y entonces
buscamos una equis que sea menor
estricto que menos cuatro o sea aquí no
tomamos al menos cuatro pero buscamos x
que estén de este lado y por aquí
tenemos que x tienen que ser mayor o
igual que menos 11 aunque hay como este
es mayor o igual entonces xy puede tomar
el valor de menos 11 y estamos buscando
x que sean mayores o iguales que menos
11 o sea que se encuentren por acá
así es que cualquier x que se encuentre
en este pedazo de recta numérica que no
incluye al menos 4 pero si incluye al
menos 11 es una solución a estas dos
desigualdades y por lo tanto el
numerador y el denominador
ambos son negativos y por lo tanto su
cociente es mayor o igual a cero ok pero
si este cociente era mayor o igual a
cero entonces se daba esta desigualdad
si es que sí
se encuentra entre menos 11 y menos 4
esas x satisfacen la desigualdad bueno
espero que lo hayas encontrado divertido
y útil y nos vemos en el próximo vídeo